[Musique]
après six semaines de déballage et d'une
couverture médiatique hors norme le
procès opposant johnny depp à amber
heard va-t-il finir par trouver une
issue on attend là les délibérations du
jury au procès qui oppose johnny depp à
amber heard depuis la mi-avril
l'amérique et le monde entier ont les
yeux rivés sur cette affaire digne d'une
série netflix a enfin rien d'un pantalon
si amber heard matière avoir été victime
de violences conjugales
space johnny depp dénonce des propos
diffamatoires hier les sept jurés
n'avaient pas encore réussi à se mettre
d'accord sur une décision unanime si
tony depp semble déjà avoir gagné le
procès médiatique rien affirme encore
que la décision du jury lui sera
favorable alors selon vous l'acteur
peut-il perdre
que se passe-t-il merci françois
durpaire d'être avec vous quand un
spécialiste hors et surtout des états
unis auteur françois durpaire et maître
nicolas robaux merci d'être avec nous
mais qui va nous dire on en est des
adverbes puisque ça passionne tout le
monde on en est où aujourd'hui gilles
verdez déjà qu'ils les dernières infos
c'est que le jury là à l'instant où on
parle vient de tomber d'accord pour le
verdict donc vendredi il s'était séparé
y avait pas d'unanimité asept juré il
n'était pas d'accord et là il vient d'y
avoir un verdict donc on va apprendre
enfin qui va gagner alors il ya cinq
hommes et deux femmes il était en plein
désaccord parce qu'il faut l'unanimité
et là ils ont trouvé donc on va savoir
qui gagne qui perd il y aura pas de
peine de prison très probablement mais
il peut y avoir des sommes de dizaines
de millions de dollars us et combien 50
millions
50 ou 100 millions de wii de médecins
quant à elle demandé
c'est incroyable on en est où françois
alors effectivement comme le vigile à
21h on a le résultat d'une heure en
heure locale
c'est difficile ça a été difficile
pourquoi parce que en fait le procès est
une catastrophe ou amber a cédé à la
bombe à plusieurs reprises elle a menti
aux etats unis c'est pas bien ça c'est
vu toute l'amérique la vue mais
attention juridiquement on verra ça
c'est plus compliqué que prévu parce que
en fait on voit que elle n'est pas
seulement victime est très clairement
elle et pas seulement victimes mais lui
ça veut pas dire qu'il n'est pas
coupable de quelque chose assure donc en
fait la difficulté du jury c'est en fait
de ne pas réfléchir uniquement à la
question agression viol tout ce qui
s'est passé d'abominables mais est ce
qu'il ya vraiment diffamation et de se
concentrer sur l'aspect diffamatoires
pour donner une anecdote l'identité des
jurés ne sera pas connu pendant toute
l'année qui vient tellement ça a
passionné les américains 300 dans les
cordes fisichella la chaîne qui a
diffusé le procès a dit que 30 330
millions de personnes avaient vu procès
il ya 330 millions d'américains ça veut
dire que tous les américains vite
surtout à bout du procès par contre il
ya trente trois personnes qui ont vu le
procès de bergerac
eh bien peut-être de dire une chose
c'est que de toute façon le résultat n'a
presque pas d'importance pourquoi parce
que amber heard a quasiment sans doute
perdu si elle gagne si elle gagne avait
été testé par l'amérique ça c'est clair
et net si elle perd y compris par les
féministes y compris parmi tous qui sont
retournés contre amber dans dix ans on
vous a si vous étiez de l'histoire du
mythe ou ya deux ans et à la mauricie
tellement menti va comme ça à
discréditer vous le mouvement en parti
et on a percé de mitu amis tous désolés
pour la blague ouais ouais ouais avec
les l'histoire de quelqu'un de
d'excréments dans le lit conjugal et
c'est grave
je suis là c'est comme mbalax et pas
dans les cieux au ban du marabout il
rien ça et si elle gagne et si elle
gagne en donne aux alcools ouais
apprendre de l'oseille mais
est en revanche si la paire bea père
hélas alors justement 28 novembre
pourraient prendre préféré prendre
beaucoup d'argent être détesté ou pas
beaucoup et être aimé o'connell âge vous
êtes vraiment un doute sur la réponse
non plus nos malades non plus jean
question qu'est ce qui se passe si elle
perd mais qu'elle est insolvable étonné
de mon temps c'est ça alors justement la
grande difficulté c'est pour ça aussi
que ça a mis du temps parce que
peut-être ils se sont décidés très vite
sur la culpabilité mais c'est de se dire
quel est le montant alors le montant
c'est très compliqué il y en a qui
demandent 50 millions avant dix ans j'ai
perdu des contrats avec disney c'est
clair mais j'ai perdu des films d'accord
mais comment on évalue des films qui
n'existe pas ou une carrière garde la
chasse à la femme est à mon sens mais
c'est très difficile à évaluer par
laquelle jurés populaires elles sont pas
décidés spécialistes ou des avocats
comme car ce sont des gens qui doivent
imaginer ça de l'autre côté 100 millions
c'est une vraie blague c'est qu'en fait
toute l'amérique s'est moqué d'elle lui
a demandé 50 ses avocats ont demandé
sans main droite devant
débat sérieux enfin je dirais l'ours
arrive à sérieux surtout qu'à la pâte
carrière face à face alors quels sont
les enjeux de ce procès nicolas robaux
les enjeux juridiques on a dit qu'ils
auraient pas de prison apparemment alors
y'a pas de prison parce que c'est un
procès civil c'est de la diffamation ce
qui est un peu particulier c'est qu'il
ya un jury populaire en france dans les
procès civils un jury populaire qui est
pas séquestrés c'est à dire que chaque
jour est rentré chez lui chaque jour il
voyait la télé chaque jour il voit les
réseaux
donc l' influence des médias etc a été
assez importante on a compris que
c'était johnny depp qui avait gagné sur
ce terrain là on a compris aussi que
amber heard a tout à perdre depuis le
début c'est à dire que même si elle
gagne elle sera détesté comme disait
françois et si elle perd de toute façon
elle a quelque part déjà perdu elle
s'est fait les en un succès sur les
réseaux sociaux etc voilà donc johnny
depp lui a déjà gagné c'est à dire que
lui en attendant regardiez et tout parce
qu'il a des problèmes vont retourner
tout ça aux états unis non pas du tout
on n'est du tout ça c'est un plus on a
vu un
de lui il va pouvoir retourner en fait
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
johnny depp s'en fichent du procès et je
pense que la plupart des juristes 10
c'est très compliqué qui gagne avant là
on le saura mais c'est très difficile de
dire il n'ya pas il y aura diffamation
parce que de toute évidence il ya eu des
coups de part et d'autre dont cap alors
là ça s'excite donc je serai le problème
c'est qu'elle a tous répertoriés elle a
tout photographié pendant toute la
relation et sont restés cinq ans
ensemble elle a pris des photos de tous
est la seule chose qu'on n'a pas cédé
photos de belles battue et en fait
c'était un des arguments de son avocat
de l'avocat de johnny depp c'est que
louis borg debbagh a tous les droits et
que s'il l'avait vraiment frappé elle
aurait ça se serait vu et il y aurait eu
des rapports de médecins et est en fait
y en a pas et il n'y a rien et alors il
ya que des photos de lui qui dort des
photos de lignes de coke sur une table
mais sans lui et donc en fait ça ça ça
porte un doute même sur la véracité des
lagons tout quoi exactement elle a tout
enregistré depuis le départ d'ailleurs
super relation toxique à l'origine
comme 6 arrêts sur des procès
et le jour le plus cruel pour elle c'est
au moment où l'avocate de johnny depp
qui est vraiment un petit génie qui lui
dit c'est bien ce jour là où vous avez
été frappé là généralement quand un
avocat dit ça de manière aussi
définitive on dit je suis pas sûr du
jour c'est peut-être le lendemain ou la
veille et dit oui c'est absolument ce
jour-là elle sort les photos d'elle en
maillot de bain disant vous avez été
frappé là vous avez l'air très en forme
ce matin à comprendre cet après midi
quand l'opinion publique en tout cas
c'est johnny depp qui a gagné parce
qu'on regarde le hashtag justice pour
johnny depp c'est 3 milliard de vues 3
millions alors que pour je suis avec
lambert hearts et 8 millions millions
week end barracuda à
il paraît qu'en plus comme à la next est
une transaction à 7 millions de dollars
et quelques dans pour le divorce elle
pourra jamais avoir plus que 7 millions
de dollars si tant est qu'elles gagnent
exactement ça l'atteignant dollars cette
non de la main sympa
6 millions de tonnes soit a perdu 7
millions d'euros dans son procès bah oui
ça que tu t'habilles comme ça
7 millions d'euros rapprochera sur un
éventail pas fait de contrats non
ça veut dire que qui on sait a pris 7
millions maintenant on me dit rien mais
j'ai perdu ça sinon met sa main qui on
sait a pris 7 millions non non ça nous
est l'épousé c'est bien mais ça arrive à
ce qu un match énorme non c'est la perte
c'est la perte c'est la paiera quoi
quand elle a pris elle a pris un petit
billet quand il aura 35
moi je les prie donc eu mais
c'est souvent le cas chez vous et
moi ça m'a coûté tous ces divorces
toutes ces conneries à résoudre dit à
peu près 7 millions à taxer le tout et
c'est l'ensemble c'est l'ensemble de
votre carrière d'accord c'est pour mon
oeuvre d'accords
après c'est pas aussi dépensier que
johnny depp is enough
dollars par jour ça va lui à 50 mille
dollars par jour réponse il a une mais
des petits capot ou à évaluer ça il a
dix ans contre 55 mille dollars va
racheter 3com match et en tout il va
t'elle un lieu dans un bar qui lui qu'il
ya c'est sympa j'achète ils achètent
c'est pas beau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai repris y était ouais ben ali la
tante ou
non mais c'est fou c'est vaut donc on
saura tout à 21h15 heure heure
américaine élément absolument on sera
tous et en effet il est possible
qu'aucun des deux n'ait gagné un match
nul ça peut être battu savard tirs au
but le caire un calme à yaya question
alors pour les jurys c'est très
convivial apprécié d'une
nation il perd le procès chacun perd en
fait chacun permet de mettre la question
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un appel oui
absolument alors la moindre recours aux
états unis un appel il y en a je peux y
avoir un appel et puis j'avais essayé de
judiciariser
pas attendu avant juin
seules quelques personnes peuvent
comprendre ça
les plus érudits d'ancône bien est-ce
qu'il veut barracuda alors juste ils
peuvent aller aussi au bénin derrière
bien sûr elle a dit au procès c est le
juge d'ailleurs c'est dit comment ça se
fait que les profits de cet internat
pour parler d'un viol on imagine qu'en
fait lui porter plainte avant elle fait
une tribune devant washington post et à
la temps le procès pour dire qu'elle
était violée il y avait des passages
glauquissime dans le procès mam était
difficile ou et viol avec une bouteille
le juge lui dit qu'elle forme de
bouteille enfin s'il fallait vraiment
s'accrocher pour voir c'est à dire c'est
le premier si le premier procès
intégralement sur witch il ya eu 110 les
330 millions d'américains mixer tous les
110 millions
vers l'avant vers l'est